TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey there.
My name is Timothy Jordan, and
I'm a developer advocate on
the Glass team.
And today I'm going to
talk to you about
Invocation voice commands.
Now, if you take a look at these
slides, you'll see the
OK Glass menu.
And down there at the bottom
are two new voice commands,
Take a Note and Post
an Update.
It's pretty cool
how these work.
Let's take a look at some
examples, and then talk in
some more detail.
First off, Path.
Now, Path is using the Post
an Update command.
All a user needs to do to use
this is to say OK, Glass, post
an update, and then they
speak their update.
A new timeline item will be
created and inserted in that
user's timeline and
shared with Path.
Path will get that notification,
grabbed the
transcribed text, and post
it to the user's Path.
Now, all Path had to do to plug
into the OK Glass menu
was adjust their
share contact.
Now, this is really
the coolest part.
They've taken their existing
share contact and added the
Accept Commands value and
specified Post an Update.
That's it.
Let's take a look at
another example.
Here's Evernote.
Now, user will say OK, Glass,
take a note, and then they'll
just speak their note.
A new timeline item
will be created
and shared with Evernote.
Evernote will get that
notification, grab the
transcribed text, and
create a note.
And again, it was super
easy for Evernote.
They just updated the share
contacts for all their users
to include Accept Commands
specifying Take a Note.
Pretty cool, huh?
Now, a couple notes
about this.
First off, if multiple Glassware
want to use the same
voice command, let's say Take
a Note, then the user will
have to specify the service.
But it's really easy.
All they'll need to
say is OK, Glass,
Take a Note with Evernote.
And they'll be prompted
to do so with the
list of services available.
Now, if your display name for
your share contact is
difficult to speak, you'll
also want to include a
speakable name.
You can strip out any special
characters and make it really
easy for us to recognize.
One last thing.
We're introducing just two voice
commands with XE8, but
we'd like to do more in future
releases, and we'd love your
input and your suggestions
for which ones to use.
So we've set up this form where
you can specify the
actions you'd like a user to be
able to take from the OK,
Glass menu for your Glassware.
Just go ahead over to the form,
put in some actions that
you'd like the user to take, and
also give us a few details
about your Glassware.
To get more information about
this feature and to get to
this form, please follow
this link.
Thanks so much.